Guys CS:GO can get pretty serious sometimes.
Round by round, decision by decision, the stress is real.
I mean do we eco, do we go aggressive, should we stack a site.
Should I buy head armour?
Or 'nades. It's all too much sometimes.
That's why occasionally you just got to chill out and buy that shotgun.
I mean I don't know about you, but to me nothing lightens the mood in a server.
Like a good old XM rush.
That's right guys get pumped up (See what I did there). This week we're taking a look at the Top 10 Shotgun
Kills in CS:GO
Kicking off our list at number 10 is CLG’s
Hazed, who pulled off an incredible feat during ESL ESEA Pro League Season 1.
Looking to build up some money for the next round against Team Liquid, hazed puts his
trusty shotgun to good use by mowing down TL, one terrorist after another.
(Casting)
Coming in  at number 9, we have TSM’s Dev1ce, who, with his team in the lead decided to take
down most of Penta Esports in style.
(Casting)
Next up our list is GeT_RiGhT who pulled off a jaw dropping ace against Natus Vincere,
during Fragbite Masters 2014.
Using the Mag-7 to its fullest on Train, GeT_RiGhT decimates the CIS squad, proving that no matter
what weapons you give him, the Swedish legend will make it work.
(Casting)
Who says flicks are just for AWPs.
Coming at number 7 is GODSENT’s Doplan who, at ESL Pro League Season 6, proved that shotgun
flicks are just as sick.
With Envy already on Cache’s B-site, Doplan found himself trapped with only a mag-7 in hand.
But of course, he didn’t see it that way.
(Casting)
Nothing spells confidence more than running through a molly with a shotty.
Which is why Flusha comes in at number six on our list.
Taking on Vexed Gaming during StarSeries Season 14, Fnatic found themselves with a commanding
lead, and with the round coming to an end Flusha decided it was time to go hunting.
(Casting)
I’d imagine at this point you might be getting tired of the Mag-7.
Well we're not. Since time and time again pros have been able to pop off heads and make it flashy.
That's not different here with NBK showing us just how versatile he is as a player
And unfortunately for Dignitas, they’d be used as the demonstration dummies
(Casting)
At number 4 we have Fnatic’s Olofmeister at ESL One Cologne 2014.
On the cusp of losing the map to Virtus.Pro, The Swedes needed to come up with some sort
of brilliant play to save themselves.
So what better than letting Olofmeister live up to his famous Olofpass nickname.
(Casting)
Shotguns are big guns, so we thought that the number three spot on our list should be
held down by the man with biggest guns in CS:GO
Most player don’t like taking too many risks with their money during the semifinal of a
Major, but then again, most players aren’t PashaBiceps.
And at ESL Once Cologne 2016, Pasha used a Mag-7 to remind SK Gaming exactly why VP
are Counter-Strike legends.
(Casting)
Is it actually possible to be sneaky with a shotgun?
Well apparently Tizian thought so and wanted to prove it against DRUCKSWELLE esports in
ESL’s Meisterschaft league.
Already ahead 5 rounds, Tizian decided to change things up and buy a Nova before putting
on his best Stewie2k impression and kindly showing Druckswelle the power of his boomstick.
(Casting)
Taking the number one spot, with his second appearance on this list is Swedish legend
GeT_RiGhT, who scored an unbelievable ace against CPLAY at NorthCon 2012.
With everyone still trying to figure out the ins and outs of CS:GO, few players knew what
weapons to expect when it came to an eco round.
So with no armor against a full buy, GeT_RiGhT went on to set the standard for what makes
a great shotgun play.
(Casting)
Well guys that's our list of the TOp 10 Shotgun Kills in CS:GO
Now look, if you're looking for more venomous gaming athleticism, be sure to check out our Story
of Dr. Disrespect and that's dropping this Saturday.
That's all for me though guys and I will see you next time.
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.